Joe Biden began his tour of the Republic
of Ireland with some ancestral
exploration in County louth's Coulee
Peninsula his ancestors the Finnegans
left the area for a new life in America
in 1849 the last major landmark they
would have seen was carningford castle
where the president was given a tour
as the rain poured down President Biden
arrived in Dundalk it was time for a
short Walkabout meeting local business
owners before heading to a pub somewhat
improbably called The Windsor here a
clearly relaxed president felt at home
in a sense I know why my ancestors and
many of your relatives left during the
famine
and uh but uh you know when you're here
you wonder why anyone ever want to leave
I mean it
so it's good to be back it was however
also the venue for the first goth of the
presidential visit paying tribute to his
distant cousin Rob Carney a former Irish
Rugby International he said this you see
this tie I have with the Shamrock on it
this was given to me by one of these
guys right here it was a hell of a rugby
player and they beat that little black
and tans oh my God clearly confusing New
Zealand's old blacks for the reviled
British paramilitary Force the black and
tans which tried to brutally suppress
Irish Independence it was a blip on a
day the proud irish-american otherwise
appeared to enjoy look at this Air Force
One
his next round of engagements returns to
a more political theme in Dublin
meetings with the Irish Prime Minister
and president and addressing a joint
session of the Irish Parliament we can
expect his comments there to stick more
tightly to script
Stephen Murphy Sky News in County louth